Speaker 2: Let's hear from some people
in the audience through Discord. You can
find our discord at David Pakman dot
com slash discord. Let's start today
with Nevin in Tennessee. Nevin, welcome
to the show. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 1: Hey, David, I just wanted to ask about.
Speaker 4: What your opinion is on the
revolutionary left. And a lot of people in
revolutionary left I've found have for some reason
support China and Russia and the Ukraine invasion.
Speaker 1: So I just wanna know
your thoughts on that. Yeah.
Speaker 2: You know, I think one of the things
about the revolutionary left is they're they
claim to be against imperialism and colonialism
when it's the United States and do not apply the
same standards to other countries. Now, of course,
sometimes circumstances are different in other
countries than in the United States. If you take
a country without a colonial history that's tiny
with a small economy or whatever. It would be
logical to think about the country differently
than the United States. But there are certain
principles that to me. Are of paramount
importance. I'm against authoritarianism,
I'm against theocracy. I'm against, you
know, all these different things. So when
I see authoritarianism in China or in Venezuela
or wherever. I'm against that because that's an
important principle to me. And I would like to see
these so-called revolutionary leftists maybe apply
those standards uniformly.
Speaker 1:
Okay. Thanks for my question. Congrats on.
Speaker 4: 1.5 million subscribers, by the.
Speaker 2: Way. Thank you. And we are heading on
to 2 million. That's the new that's the new goal.
And I hope that we get there soon.
Speaker 1:
Yeah.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
All right. Good. Never. Not super excited about
2 million, but that's okay. We're going to we're
going to work towards it's going to be a great
thing. Let's go next to win from Indiana Win.
Welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 4: Hey, David, how are you doing? I'm
doing well. I still have an exam in,
like, 3 hours in regulatory economics.
Mm hmm. So I have a question on monopolies.
Okay. So what are your views on, like,
not really regulating monopolies? Because what
I've learned and like from game theory and such,
some monopolies are actually good where you
can compete with bigger firms. I'm kind of
paraphrasing, but I'm not sure I articulated well.
Speaker 2: Well, so here's the thing. The problem
with monopoly power is that it becomes so you've
got to first you've got to back up and you have
to say, what are our principles here? If you claim
to be about allowing markets to direct resources,
right? Like if you're a supplant supply
and demand guy, for lack of a better term,
you have to recognize that a monopoly is getting
out of pure supply and demand because the monopoly
can get a stranglehold on an industry to the
point where normal market forces no longer apply,
either because of barriers to entry or
the dynamics of market share, or for other
reasons. So if you claim to care about markets,
directing resources and supply and demand,
then it follows that you have to be against most
monopolies. Now there can be exceptions. There
could be areas of society where, for example,
I, as a social Democrat, think that in certain
areas we don't want markets to direct resources.
So I've talked about health care, I've talked
about public education and some others. You
might decide that there are certain areas where
monopoly power is actually okay or good, either
for regulatory reasons or whatever. But the first
question is what is your view on markets directing
resources? That has to be answered first before
you can answer the question about monopoly power.
Speaker 4: Mm hmm. So what I'm getting at is,
like, social efficiency. So, for example, in the
event where there's, like a, let's say, Walmart
or whatever, it's like a big, big retail company.
And there are like the NSA, there's Walmart and
there's other three small retail companies. Yeah.
Walmart is like the dominant like they have the
majority market share. Is do you think it's
okay if you allow the two smaller industries,
I mean, two smaller companies to merge in order to
compete with Walmart because, you know, Walmart is
dominating a market share. Now, if the government
allows the two other companies to come to merge,
that would be a competitor to Walmart, which
reduces Walmart's market share. Therefore, it
creates a better competition if that's going to.
Speaker 2: Still has the lion's share of the
market share, even after the merger of the two
smaller players. The monopoly issue really isn't
with the merger of the two smaller players. It's
with Walmart and you've still got an oligopoly
primarily controlled by one player. So you're
absolutely correct. I don't think it, actually.
Is a tough one because the merger of the two
smaller companies doesn't change the dynamics
of Wal-Mart as the monopoly or the near monopoly.
Speaker 4: But it could become a duopoly, right?
Speaker 2: Yes, it could. Absolutely.
Speaker 4: And would you be in favor of
that? Because you are you are a social
Democrat and you believe in markets.
Speaker 2: Depends on the industry.
Depends on the specific. It's such
a specific question. You've really got to
look at the particulars of the situation.
Very hard to answer in the abstract.
Speaker 4: Gotcha. Gotcha. Yeah. So like,
yeah, I'm actually like looking into it like
according to, like looking at the market share
and like the math behind it, like the whether
if this two companies merge, is it really going
to create social efficiency, which means like is
it going to give more options to consumers if you
know what I'm getting at? Because that is a very.
Speaker 2: Important question to be asking. And
also, does it benefit consumers, many of these
telecom mergers, when you ask that question,
you say, well, actually, it's not really
going to be good for consumers in any way.
It will probably just lead to higher
prices and worse customer service.
Speaker 4: Hmm. Yeah. Was this a.
Speaker 2: Good luck on the exam, my friend?
Speaker 4: Oh, thank you so much.
Speaker 2: All right. There is wind from Indiana.
Very, very important question. Let's go next
to Chris from Austin, Texas. Chris from Austin,
what's on your mind today? Chris from Austin,
Texas, you were unmuted, but we can't hear you,
which probably means you have the wrong audio
device selected in Discord. Chris from Austin,
Texas, go ahead. And last chance for
Chris from Austin, Texas, whose audio
is not working. And there it is, Chris
from Austin, Texas, with a technical issue